Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Wow.
What's going on?
It's bill burr is some Monday morning podcast.
So Monday,
February 6th,
2017 I'm doing it right after the Superbowl.
Um,
just cause I got the little one now and she's going to keep me up all night.
So I knew there was no way is everybody texted me right now.
MMM.
I'm speechless.
Something you never hear from me.
I'm always running my mouth.
I am absolutely speechless.
Speechless.
I cannot believe we came back and won that game.
I'm not going to be that guy.
God Dude,
I knew it.
I was like,
I had this feeling right.
I said this,
I didn't,
I had my fucking head in the oven at halftime.
We were so getting our ass kicked at like 21 to nothing when Brady threw a pick
six.
I have this theory at the NFL level that if you throw a pick six,
you don't win the game.
The too fucking good.
It's the most devastating fucking play.
Literally.
You know?
So I saw him one time at NFL films.
One of the players said that you are trying to score not only these other teams
stop you,
they turn around and score on that fucking play.
It's like,
I,
I can't believe it.
21,
three then was 28 to three.
I wasn't even like a,
I actually texted us somebody going like,
this is the longest fucking loss I've ever watched in my life.
I'm like,
this is just slowly going to,
what is this going to end up being like 35,
10 and they gonna bring that dare fucking bench in.
Um,
I had completely mentally thrown in the towel and I was just sitting here.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
and I couldn't scream and yell,
I've got my girl now and it's just,
it's hilarious.
I'm just sitting here going,
well,
if she's keeping me calm,
but there was so kicking our ass,
I couldn't even get upset.
MMM.
And if you watched,
when I was promoting,
uh,
my special,
and when people would ask me about the game I was,
I was not comfortable at all.
And you know,
I went from like,
not even believing in Atlanta against Seattle,
picking against them again when they played green bay.
And I was just,
after I saw the way they played,
I was like,
man,
they got,
they got a great running back.
They got Julio Jones,
Matt Ryan seems dialed in,
all that shit that I sent.
And then right before the super bowl,
they're like,
dude,
they don't have one running back.
They got to,
they got that Coleman guy too.
So I was like,
fuck this.
I Dunno.
I just had,
I had that fucking,
you know that feeling you have when you get,
you think your team's going to lose,
but you,
you,
you don't want to say it.
That's why I was saying everybody,
uh,
on those shows going like,
you know,
I'd bet the under,
um,
which didn't come in and I said I would like the falcons getting,
if I could get five.
I think that I wasn't comfortable taking the Patriots given points.
MMM.
So I can't say I called it on any fucking level.
I didn't.
I am absolutely fucking speechless.
I can't believe it.
I just cannot believe it.
And uh,
I've never said this before,
but I think I can finally say it.
I think Tom Brady's the greatest of all time.
I always gave the nod to Montana because he went to four.
It took him four trips to win four.
But even then,
it's always up for debate because what if Montana had Bella check what you have
is the greatest head coach in arguably,
arguably the greatest,
if not now,
five rings.
It's a great argument.
The greatest fucking quarterback of all fucking time,
you know,
playing together.
I can't,
I cannot fucking believe it.
I,
and I didn't have any emotion the whole game.
I just,
cause we just so fucking losing.
So I was just sitting there and then as we move slowly,
I wasn't,
I wasn't even call saying that we were coming back.
I was la.
Maybe they'll make it a little respectable.
I don't know.
All right.
You know,
maybe we just lose by 10 and then,
you know,
we scored that first two point conversion.
Even then when we were going down the field,
I'm like,
what are the odds?
We're going to get another fucking two point conversion.
We fucking missed a field goal.
We fucking screwed up.
And,
uh,
the,
the onside kick and I'm to the greatest Superbowl catches I've seen since the
helmet catch,
uh,
was Julio Jones,
Jesus Christ and what a fucking throw Matt Ryan was also running when he made
that throw.
I was like,
oh my God,
every fucking Superbowl now,
every Superbowl that there's that fucking ghost of [inaudible].
It is an Eli.
It's like the ghost of Eli fucking throw.
And for once we had a Edelman,
we had a circus catch back.
And,
um,
I dunno,
I,
I'm absolutely stunned.
And having said all that,
my condolences to the Atlanta Falcons fans.
I got no beef with you guys.
And I've been there plenty of fucking times.
Um,
certainly for the first,
you know,
36 years of my life,
if there was a fucking way to choke away a Goddamn game,
I saw a Boston team do it.
And for whatever fucking reason,
I don't know why this is happening.
I don't know why it's happened this fucking long,
just trying to enjoy it.
He says how spoiled Boston fans are.
My daughter's two weeks old and she's already seen her first Boston title.
It's fucking unbelievable.
And,
um,
I got a big kick out of Bill Maher trash the Patriots.
At first I thought it was,
he just trashing,
see talking sports.
That's like me talking politics.
This guy's getting outside of his lane.
But then I saw he was man,
I guess he was mad cause uh,
you know,
Brady and I guess somebody else.
I don't pay attention to all those fucking soap opera shit.
I guess they're like Trump supporters.
And I heard on the radio that,
you know,
I dunno Brady did or didn't go when Obama was there.
I don't fucking know.
So this,
this,
if the Patriots are,
aren't at the height of their hatred,
if he shows up now,
if he didn't go to the,
Oh,
the Obama thing and then shows up at the Trump thing,
that's going to be a complete shit show.
But they seem to thrive being hated.
So what a fucking season starts off with that fucking horse shit.
The biggest,
uh,
the as like witch hunt I've ever seen in my life,
that stupid fucking deflate gate thing and just all the justice that came out of
it,
the fact that it went to court,
it got laughed out of court to the point.
The judge was actually pissed.
Then they finally get the fucking thing.
They just,
I don't know,
they just,
oh well does,
we're a corporation.
We have a right to suspend our employee.
Yes you do.
He's our employee.
You're fucking suspended.
So then he sits there for fucking games and I just started thinking,
well five games in,
we have a rested pissed off Tom Brady without those fucking miles.
Maybe that'll be a good thing.
And just how poetic was the whole thing?
Do you know that line back from Indianapolis?
So I don't have any fucking beef with,
cause he said he didn't want to be in the middle of it,
but the linebacker who caught the ball that he brought to the sideline as a
souvenir,
um,
that touched off the whole deflate gate thing.
He tested positive for steroids and you got a four game suspension.
It's funny how we,
ESPN really didn't do,
you know,
you'd think they'd still be talking about that.
Yep.
Never happened.
You know?
Um,
and I also thought it was funny,
Bill mark called this cheaters as we're playing the Atlanta Falcons who got
busted pumping fucking crowd noise in,
but that's okay.
It's okay.
Who gives a fuck?
You know an NBA when they go,
you know,
on basketball they go,
the ball don't lie.
That's when I feel like just fucking happened.
After all of that shit vindication,
he comes back and he wins it.
And then Roger Goodell like,
like the end of a fucking diehard movie,
the police commissioner who didn't fucking believe in the rogue cop has to come
in and finally give in and be like,
you know what?
You are a good cup.
Here's your gun and your badge back.
Right?
Brady sitting there with his fucking dirty fucking wife Beater on
Jesus Christ and I will never fucking ever tell him you don't.
Keith Robinson called it.
I'm going to find the fucking text message.
I'm going to read you some of these fucks in texts right now because I hate when
fucking people fucking quit,
you know,
and then they don't admit to it.
I did.
I was like this,
this game is fucking over.
They're younger,
they're faster.
And then we,
we get a break in the game,
then they get a fucking big sack.
I mean,
there are really,
really good team.
Um,
hang on,
let me find this fucking thing.
I had a buddy of mine,
he texts me at halftime.
He said I took Atlanta and the under and I was like,
great bed.
I didn't hear from till after the overtime and then he texts me,
he just texts fixed.
Um,
all right.
Oh my God.
I felt so bad for fucking Atlanta's owner.
He seems like such a great guy,
you know,
and you know,
he looks like fucking grandpa monster and he made the fucking Cherry Jones.
Did Jerry Jones move?
You come down on the field before you put the game away.
Then he had to stand there.
You just see when he had that glum look on his face and his,
I don't know what it,
you know,
you never know what those super rich guys,
it's like,
is that your daughter or your fucking third wife?
Whoever the fuck that was with them just sort of glanced down.
I'm like Oh God,
he's going to be hitting the bottle.
That poor bastard.
Um,
all right.
Where are,
where is it?
Uh,
okay,
what did I say here?
Yeah.
Okay.
So first text I sent at 4:55 PM Pacific coast time.
Have I ever told you might pick six rule.
If you throw a pick six during the NFL game,
you lose.
Not to mention we are down 21 nothing.
I bet the under its 59 the pate,
if the Patriots don't start playing defense to Falcons,
we'll score 60 lol.
He writes how hard the falcons give up a lead all the time.
He said that at 21 nothing.
This is Keith Robinson while now say the great Keith Robinson,
Tom Brady,
the greatest of all time.
Keith Robinson.
He's the Greg Keith Robinson.
All right.
Then I wrote,
we look like shit against the Texans and the Steelers weren't that tough.
Uh,
okay.
Six,
19:00 PM this loss is taking forever.
I had no belief.
Um,
you know,
Glenn close in the natural when she stands up and he looks into the stands.
If,
if,
uh,
let's say me and Robert Redford had an alternative lifestyle relationship,
when he looked up in the stance,
I would have been gone.
What does seeing the back of my head walking out of the fucking stadium,
um,
he goes,
they can still come back.
And I just,
I just laughed.
I laughed at him and I just said,
they are younger and faster.
AFC was weak and then there's no more texts for a while.
They writes back,
told you,
and then I wrote,
right,
you might be right.
Uh,
then I wrote,
that's one of the best catches I've ever seen.
That was a,
the Julio Jones.
And then I wrote this grandpa monster on the falcons since when he was down on
the thing.
And then after that he was just calling me up and he just kept saying,
this is what Atlanta does.
And I was like,
you're right.
You're absolutely right.
I don't know,
but you know,
okay.
I sat and watched the whole fucking thing.
Thank God I didn't turn on some Mary Tyler Moore tribute.
By the way.
God rest her soul.
One of my favorites of all time.
MMM.
I cannot fucking believe it.
I cannot fuck him.
I just sat here.
MMM.
I just accepting defeat going like,
oh well,
you know,
we'll see what the fuck I can't,
I can't fucking believe it.
I can't believe it.
So there you go.
Five fucking rings,
Tom Brady,
the greatest of all time.
And uh,
once again,
I always have to say this,
cause I fucking,
I went to that Green Bay packers,
a patriots' Superbowl,
you know Jesus Christ.
I watched the fucking,
when the first year I watch the red sox was 1978.
Bucky Dent.
I still remember my mother's face and the kitchen
came in and I was like,
mom,
is there another game tomorrow?
She just looked over at me and didn't say anything.
She just shook her head,
shook it now.
Oh fuck.
Anyways.
Um,
all right.
Enough of that.
I don't even know what else to fucking talk about.
Um,
I got uh,
Oh,
you know what?
I did the ice house this weekend.
It was the first time.
It was great to see the bushes,
by the way,
cause I know that they were in the fucking the hospital,
whatever.
Regardless of your politics guys,
a war hero,
you don't want to see somebody fucking,
I mean,
I guess your die at some point,
right.
You know,
it took a lot of balls from to go out there.
I want it done that.
You know what I mean?
I get to my,
those fucking years.
You fucking wheeling me around and Shit it bill,
you want to throw the coin?
You know you want to fucking flip the coin in the beginning of the super bowl.
You out of your fucking mind.
I want to go out in public and throw a coin in a fun.
When people see me like this
blood pressure going through the fucking roof.
Um,
okay.
Oh fuck.
Now the showing the highlights,
you know,
you know what I really officially thought the game was over was when we called
that fucking trick play in Atlanta.
It didn't even,
they didn't even,
they covered that too.
And I'm just like,
these guys are just fucking dialed in.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
yeah.
So I did the ice house this weekend and everything I talk about after this is
going to fucking pale in comparison.
The four Boston teams have won in,
in this century 10 fucking titles,
Dude.
Rappaport's hilarious.
He fucking text me before the game.
Yeah.
He goes,
hey,
if you guys lose today,
you know,
I'm calling you and you better take my call.
And I said,
Oh yeah.
I go,
what if the Patriots win?
Am I going to hear from you?
And he said,
no,
I'll be at temple.
So at halftime I got my fucking head in the oven muttering to myself just
walking around.
I can't,
I'm not watching the lady,
God,
God Dang.
I thought she did a great job,
but I got,
I got it.
I always get nervous when somebody is coming down on those fucking wire things
that basically look like crazy straws that you straightened out.
I always feel like it at some point,
one of those things,
it's going to snap and somebody is going to fall to their fucking death.
You,
you,
there's no fucking Gig in the world worth doing that.
The people who fucking do that,
uh,
the,
the level of faith that they have,
there's no fucking way I would do that.
But anyways,
so I'm out there model and modern in the kitchen trying to think what,
how the fuck I'm going to graciously congratulate the Atlanta fans,
you know,
and the amount of shit and I'm looking at my Twitter and all these fucking
Atlanta fans.
Where are you Billy boy?
Hey,
they're freckles.
You'd been all quiet and I'm just muttering in the kitchen to myself,
you know,
it was lady Gaga is on it.
Okay.
Right.
Um,
I guess my kid kept me calm.
I just walked in as pissed as I wasn't pissed.
I was just fucking,
I was,
I almost said deflated.
How funny is that?
I was,
yeah,
I was just fucking,
I was depressed.
I was like,
oh my God.
I mean Jesus,
it's one thing to lose,
but you just get your fucking ass kick.
So I'm out there and uh,
I mean,
what the fuck?
I was thinking what the fuck was even talking about?
You know what it is?
I'm watching these goddamn highlights.
I'm still trying to figure out how the fuck we came back.
Um,
alright.
Tell enough already or not.
If we get it,
your team won a fucking Superbowl.
So anyways,
oh yeah.
What about that commercial during the Superbowl with that new fucking thing from
Google,
that little speaker in your house,
you sitting there talking to your kid,
reading it a story and it's fucking looking over your shoulder and then you just
go,
hey,
go low.
What noise does a whale make?
And it's like,
and then you laugh with your daughter.
Look at what point does the dad turned around?
Like,
Hey Google,
you fucking listening to all of this shit creep,
right people please for the love of fucking God,
for the love of God.
Do not bring that thing into your house.
Okay?
Okay.
That's the modern day version of bringing like,
I don't know,
a vampire or whatever.
I don't even know what it is.
Why?
Why are people so fucking stupid when it comes to their own privacy?
Okay.
That thing is just on.
What is it doing that's a listening.
You're literally bugging your own house.
I don't know.
I did the Joe Rogan podcast and he said the most depressing fucking thing.
He said they're making
okay.
Like cameras to size of grains of sand and they're just going to spread them
around like every fucking street.
So I told him I'd walk down the street with like a leaf blower.
Yeah.
It just going to be everywhere.
Everything's going to be filmed and it's just like that.
Okay.
Big Brother Shit.
And it's just that book.
It's literally going to be,
well,
if you're not doing anything wrong,
I don't know what happened,
Bill,
your team won a Superbowl.
Now you're going to fucking depress everybody anyways or the upside here.
Yeah,
I went to,
um,
okay.
I went to the ice house this weekend.
I did two shows and uh,
you know,
my special came out.
People really seem to be liking it.
Thank God.
Although,
you know,
I did get some shit.
Anytime you talk politics,
I got a lot of shift from a Trump fans and a Hillary fans,
you know,
they always start with the,
that wasn't funny.
What happened to you,
blah,
blah.
And I,
I've,
I don't know,
I've been around long enough to know like,
okay,
what was it was the,
was it the Trump fucking wall?
Joko?
Was it the fucking
okay,
Hillary's pure evil,
whatever the fuck I said.
Um,
but anyways,
I did two shows working out there with Joe Bart,
nick,
and uh,
Jimmy Burns and
I did an hour,
both shows.
I was surprised.
I was really nervous because I thought with um,
having my daughter and everything,
um,
that like,
you know,
I hadn't been going out to the clubs and we waited so long for her to come and
everything.
I was just really nervous about where my act was going to be.
So here's the deal,
everybody,
I'm going to the comedy zone.
I think it's already sold out in a Charlotte and uh,
I'm going to be working,
I'm going to be doing some clubs here over the next month or so,
uh,
two months maybe we'll figure it out once I get literally get my act together
and I'm going to try to build up this new hour.
But I was really psyched like,
and then what happened?
I went up there and I just was got into a good flow and a bunch of shit that
never said came out and then there was a bunch of shit that I,
I kind of just left behind that kind of came back and I never put it on a
special,
at least I didn't.
I always have a paranoia about that because once I do a special at once,
I'd done editing and I never watch it again.
Like why the fuck would you sit there and watch your ship?
What happens is I end up forgetting what the fuck I did from special does
special.
So there's always that danger.
I might fucking repeat something or grab a punchline from something else.
Um,
you know,
God knows I've made every fucking mistake there is to make as a comic.
So,
um,
I was very happy about that and I want to thank every the ice house for letting
me come out that way.
And um,
okay.
I Dunno.
Oh and then we missed that fucking field goal and watch the highlights right
now.
I've got to shut this off.
I gotta shut this off for this podcast is going to suck.
Probably is very suck for people.
You know I had no idea.
Fucking Atlanta.
Atlanta only one,
one fucking title.
It's entire sports' existence.
Okay.
I thought the Saint Louis Hawks.
I thought they won a title.
So though.
Okay.
You know what I gotta look that up.
Cause that's a great way to give fucking Laker fan shit.
You know if the Saint Louis Hawks actually won a fucking title.
Okay.
This is some Bill Simmons Shit here.
The St Lou.
I'm gonna hit pause cause I don't want you guys fucking city alone.
Who gives a shit?
The Saint Louis Hawks and off they fucking won a title.
They want to fucking title and Atlanta doesn't caught caught counted how the
fuck
de la Los Angeles Lakers fans count Minneapolis Lakers titles and that other
title that they haven't that they wanted like the NBL or some shit as an NBA
title.
A NBA Saint Louis Hawks and be a title.
I want to say they won one
1958 team coach when Saint Louis Hawks.
Well I thought we'd beat the hawks.
I know the Celtics beat him
cause that was at trivia question last time.
Okay.
Saint Louis lost the Superbowl.
They lost to the Patriots last time you lost a Stanley Cup final was to the
Boston Bruins last time.
The last two world series was to the Boston red sox.
Last Times they lost to the an NBA title.
The Saint Louis Hawks lost to the,
uh,
to the Boston Celtics,
but it says here in 1958 they won though.
Saint Louis Hawks say one.
Okay.
So they one,
the 1958 fucking NBA finals,
they won.
All right.
And fucking Atlanta doesn't count that.
Let me make sure I say this right.
Saint Louis Winds,
Boston,
St Louis,
St Louis.
Yeah.
They wanted six games.
Hawks when series six game Atlanta doesn't count that title.
See,
that's why la is stuff.
They're the fucking worst with that shit.
You don't,
having said that,
I totally respect the lake of franchise,
but nobody,
nobody pads,
they're fucking stats like them because it was just this game.
The Celtics had,
I believe it was Friday night,
we played the Lakers and they rebuild it and everything.
So it wasn't really like a Celtic Laker thing.
Uh,
it always sucks from the Celtics and Lakers play each other and we're not,
you know,
if one team is good,
the other sucks.
It's not fun winning or losing those games.
It's just like,
all right,
whatever this teams we're rebuilding or we're,
we're rebuilding.
But,
um,
so interestingly enough,
at that point,
all time,
the most regular season wins.
Okay.
The Lakers and Celtics were tied after all like 60 fucking years,
like 3,200 something wins a piece.
And whoever won that game night that night would go up by one.
You know what I mean?
So basically we went ahead.
They probably were ahead in the beginning in Minneapolis with George,
Mike and,
and all those guys.
We got ahead in the sixties and seventies was kind of a push in the 80s,
but in the 90s,
in the,
in the two thousands where we just had a rough time and they had those,
the Colby era,
Colby shack and all those other fucking guys,
um,
they must have caught up.
I can't imagine how many games they picked up on us during those times until,
uh,
you know,
we took a page out of their book and bought a title in 2008.
Um,
so,
uh,
anyways,
we played each other and uh,
and I remember they were showing the stats that always bugs me that they say
that they have the Los Angeles Lakers have 16 titles eating.
If you say the franchise,
it just bugs the shit out of me.
Really build doesn't really bug you when you're fucking team just won a
Superbowl.
Yeah,
I guess not really.
Not really.
Anybody watched the fucking Bruins,
a maple leafs game.
I have all the sports packages this point.
I just sit here with my daughter on my chest and I just sit there and I watch
the Games when my wife sleeps downstairs and when she cries,
I go downstairs and I just changed the diaper and she keeps crying.
That means she's hungry.
It's really kind of easy the first three months.
And um,
it sucks having to get up every like hour and eight minutes roughly at night.
But I just,
um,
I dunno,
I just go into this fucking mindset.
She just bumps me and then I wake up and I just go,
daddy daycare.
I make a little joke and I'd get up and my fucking Achilles are so fucking
tight.
Like there's something happens when you get old and I stretch all the fucking
time.
Can I stretch all the fucking time?
And um,
I don't know if you guys,
if you're an old fucking,
maybe this is,
I don't know if this is an old guy in old white guy,
an old red bald white guy thing,
but I will lay on the fucking couch.
I swear to God,
I laid on that couch.
I will lay on a couch for like fucking 12 minutes
and if I go up,
get up to go to the fucking refrigerator,
it's like the first step.
I've taken an eight hours.
I have to like literally stop drives me up the wall.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is and I,
and fucking,
no matter how much down dog stretch I do,
it just doesn't seem to be working out.
So if you have that fucking problem,
here's a great stretch case.
Some old guy shit before I even get out of bed now.
Okay.
Except now that I have a daughter,
I just made me the lead jump up because I don't want to do it.
And I know if I,
if I even contemplate,
you know,
laying there,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fall back asleep so I have to immediately jump up.
But like what I used to do before being a dad,
um,
is uh,
I've just put your point,
your toes [inaudible] niece.
Just do that for like 10 seconds and then point them the other way for like 10
seconds and then do clockwise and counterclockwise and then you can get out of
bed and for all you young consult,
they laughing at me right now.
Just remember this in 20 years.
Okay.
Cause you don't want to be that guy that blows out his fucking Achilles cause
you're never the fucking same.
All right?
Unless you got Koby Bryant money and you can go to Germany,
right?
And go see Peyton Manning's fucking doctor and they stick your fucking blood in
a centrifuge.
Whatever those fucking leftover Nazis are doing over there,
right there are running around.
Um,
yeah,
you're gonna,
uh,
you're gonna fucking pay the price.
So I gotta make sure I stay limber cause I'm,
who knows.
I don't know when,
I haven't really done a lot of research about kids even though I have one.
Um,
I know at some point they do start running around and uh,
you know,
for the first like eight,
nine years of your life being a dad is a ground game,
you know,
you got to take it to the mat.
So I gotta to make sure that I stay fucking limber.
Uh,
the best I can because I don't want to be that fucking,
you know,
I'm an old,
I am an old dead,
but I'm a fucking psycho so that I will,
I will energy my way through this.
You know what I mean?
You know what I'm gonna be,
I'm going to be like Steve Brogan,
my fatherhood.
I'm going to be like fucking Steve Grogan during the neck brace years and I'm
just going to tough it out.
You know,
man,
when he would just stand there and there,
this is back when you could hit a quarterback and you would just see this
fucking guy running full speed and he would stand there until the last second.
And then he'd let it fly to Morgan.
And right as they started the follow the ball,
you just see the beginning of the impact and Steve Grogan and the other guy
would go flying out of the right side of your screen as they follow the ball to
the left.
Um,
that's going to be me
as a fucking quarterback.
I mean as a,
as a dad.
So,
um,
anyways,
so I hit the road,
I go to,
um,
you know,
I'm going to a Charlotte,
going to go to the comedy zone and I'm doing a couple of shows out there.
Uh,
if I get there early night,
not if I'm going to go to the shallot Hornets game and,
um,
and,
and I'm closing in by the way.
And I'm going to Duke Carolina and empty,
you know,
and I'm not smoking cigars cause I got this fucking life insurance thing and I
gotta tell you I'm smoked a cigar and like,
well over two months and I feel fucking,
I feel good about,
you know,
so I don't know.
I might just keep going.
Who knows?
Um,
it can't be that smelly dead coming in smelling like,
like I went to the track,
oh,
big fucking thing in my life.
My wife might let me bring the fucking,
the game changer.
You know,
the flat top grill.
We've got it fucking downstairs in my backyard.
Right.
And uh,
so the kitchen's fucking upstairs does Atlanta,
this house is completely fucked up,
right?
So I got to run up and down the fucking stairs,
you know,
it's a pain in the ass.
So I finally,
she,
cause I got,
I got rid of a ton of shit.
Um,
I put my,
uh,
my old Ludwig kit up for sale.
Um,
dissembles everything.
It's the whole fucking John Bonham set up.
1971 green sparkle,
Ludwig,
uh,
all the pasty symbols.
Even the Rogers high hat that he had.
I'm finally letting go of that.
That fan boy era is done.
You know,
I had a lot of fun with that kit,
but it's just fucking gigantic and a 26 inch bass drum.
I don't want that.
You know what I want?
I want to,
I want to 12,
14,
16,
22 kick ass.
What the fuck I want.
I never liked the sound of those symbols.
I liked the high hats,
but I never liked the sound of is the fucking right.
He could make it sound good.
I couldn't.
Um,
so I've been getting into a bunch of other different sounds,
all this shit that I always heard in my fucking head.
I really just kinda came to this realization,
okay.
As someone who does that as a hobby that,
uh,
I dunno,
that was you.
You're not really creating,
you're just sort of recreating when you do shit like that.
Like you,
you get so into what musician that you want to buy,
all the shit,
the exact shit that they had and then what?
It's fucking,
it's just,
yeah,
I dunno.
There was just,
I just kept picturing John Bonham coming back to life and for whatever reason,
walking into my house and then I go,
oh my God,
John bought them.
Eh,
you're like Jesus,
but you're a drummer.
Come on Ed.
Hey,
the way you know I'm a huge fan of yours.
Yeah.
Come on.
Chica,
my drum kit.
And he would walk in and see his exact drum kit right down to the Rogers high
hat and then he would get like that fucking,
I was joking with a buddy of mine today.
Oh,
a text.
He would get that single white female vibe for me and he would just slowly back
out of the room like,
Hey,
yeah,
that's great.
This guy just fucking leave.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I'm going to go out.
I'm trying out all the kits.
I heard that Gretsch broadcaster with the three plies,
fucking,
you know,
has a great sound DW,
obviously amazing drums.
I grew up,
everybody that I watched used to play the Tam is Tom or how the fuck you say it?
Pearl?
Uh,
the Ludwigs um,
you know,
it's funny,
I feel right.
Always played sonar or whatever.
And uh,
the Great Benny Greg plays those,
but they,
they know fucking nobody has them.
They're like these amazing fucking drums is super expensive.
And,
uh,
I've never seen,
I've never seen him,
um,
you know,
not that I go to guitar center anymore.
You know,
I go this,
there's a place out here called uh,
uh,
professional drum shop and they got some great shit out there.
Plus it's more,
you know,
they're like a legendary place,
dude,
I went in there,
I know this is all drum shit,
but I ran to a drum recently.
He goes,
talk more drums,
man.
So I fuck it.
I talked to enough sports here,
right?
Oh,
I didn't talk about,
he seemed McQuaids fight.
He fought this guy,
I think that his last name is Smith.
Um,
oh my God.
They had a great fight.
It was an old school haymaker thing.
And,
um,
McQuade got the best of him in the end just to fucking tough guys.
But I'm McQuaid got the last shot in and the guy kind of went down.
But I mean the guy took a bunch of shots.
But of course maple leaf fans.
Well like,
Oh but Quaids wearing his shield.
What a fucking secret.
I love when people say no matter what,
no matter how much,
how convincing your guy wins the fight,
there's always a fucking excuse.
But then my wife goes,
yeah,
cause I was reading the comments and go,
this is fucking unreal cause I'm sitting there going like,
well why didn't Smith just punch McQuaids fucking helmet off the way McQuade did
to him?
There was always that option.
Right.
Um,
but when I brought it up,
the leaf fans were bitching that McQuade had on a visor.
My wife goes,
yeah,
I was going to ask you about that.
And I was just like,
yeah,
all right.
And he's got on half a welder's mask maybe,
you know,
throwing up
over and under most shots go to the side of the helmet anyways.
Right.
I'm old enough to remember when guys who did wear helmets,
fought guys who had helmets and then that was the pussy move.
And now I guess to Pussy move is,
you know,
you can keep your fucking helmet on,
is somebody else's cutting up the fucking hand,
punching the plastic.
But if you have a visor then you're a pussy.
I don't get it.
All I know is McQuaids one of the best fighters,
one of the toughest guys in the league.
And it was a great fucking fight.
And that game,
even though we lost,
was unbelievable.
Was it six to five or something like that?
Five to four.
I can't even remember.
A Bruins and leaves,
always have great games,
really have great games.
And um,
you know,
even though we law,
I think we lost the last two,
we won three in a row,
but the Bruins a playing way better,
way better.
And uh,
they're plane like the Bruins again,
you know,
and I think we're actually up to like the seventh seed,
so all the fucking belly ache and that I'm doing,
I should have just kept my fucking mouth shut.
Cause,
uh,
who knows,
you know,
now people write articles.
Are they picking too early?
So anyways,
the drum talk,
get back to the drum shit.
Um,
yeah,
ran into somebody saying,
oh,
you should fucking talk more about that drum stuff.
So that's basically what I want to do.
And then I want to get like a just to,
I can't even like,
uh,
trying to explain the sound to a buddy of mine that I'm looking for with
symbols,
but I'm going to try all of them out.
Sabian's Meinl I love the sound of those things.
At least.
You know what's weird is you see the professional guys play them and they make
them sound so fucking good.
And then you buy the exact one and then you liked it doesn't sound the way it's
thought of when he did it.
That's Kegera Committee.
Um,
so uh,
yeah,
so I'm going to sell that kit and then the money I get from that,
I'm going to,
the game plan is to buy that new kid brand fucking new.
No more of this fucking old shit trying to figure stuff out.
Oh,
that was going to say about that pro drum shop place is how fucking great that
places,
I had a snare stand and I'm one of the,
you know the thing you screw into to hold it into place,
whatever the fuck you call it.
What you call that a nut?
I have no idea.
All I know is that got stripped and it didn't.
It didn't work anymore.
Now if you ever went to guitar center,
they'd be like,
Oh,
you know you've got to buy a new one.
I walked into there and the guy just takes it and he went in the back.
He fucking machine the thing so it worked again.
He goes,
hey,
go.
I was like,
how much?
He's like,
Hey,
I know three bucks,
four bucks.
That doesn't exist anymore.
Do you know whether that still exists?
Straight across the board in one industry is when you go to a cobbler,
you go into a fucking shoe store.
Those guys,
they don't give a shit.
They're in there with all those chemicals.
They don't even know what fucking year it is.
You haven't tried to go into a newest shoe store where they,
where were they actually repair shoes?
A cobbler.
I guess.
It seems weird to use that word but it,
I think that's what it is.
Right?
Um,
the modern day blacksmith a cobbler and you go in that you can't even fucking
breathe.
You gotta do that thing where you're trying to pinch your nostrils together as
you talked to him yet.
Can you like he fixed his belt.
Can you are put some more sold on these and the guy's like,
hey,
we never used it and they never take like,
it's always like cash.
They're like right now to receipt.
You can't read any of their fucking writing.
I Dunno.
This is one of those,
you know something that's like a great place for like one of those fucking Harry
Potter type of movies to start like a new franchise.
Something about when you go to a cobbler,
it's like stepping back into time and they'd be seen,
there'd be some old weird guy maybe played by Billy crystal.
They put some prosthetics on his nose is some shit.
Then you do that one time with that guy,
that guy from the Washington bullets.
Mayurasana did they do a movie together?
I don't know what the fuck it was one of those Ebeneezer scrooge fucking movies.
But anyways,
you think he going to the cobbler and there's some sort of back room area.
I love pitching out ideas for movies cause I'm never going to,
I'm not going to fucking write one might go through that fucking
axe grinder,
that fucking whore.
I,
why would you do that to yourself?
You know what I mean?
If you can travel the country telling shit and Dick Jokes,
why on fucking earth would you walk into that fucking heartbreaking of a fucking
arena.
So I'm just only movie idea I have.
I'm just throwing out there and I hope somebody fucking rights it makes it,
I hope you make a fucking billion dollars.
I don't give a shit.
You know why?
Because the Patriots Super Bowl and Tom Brady's the greatest quarterback of all
time.
You could say it now.
Five fucking rinks.
Ah God,
Jesus Christ.
Do you know sad?
Do you know he's fucking sad people?
There are right now,
and I don't just mean in Atlanta,
I just meet Patriot haters in general because the Patriots had been so fucking
successful and they've been so fucking vilified,
you know,
for the shit that they do that everybody else fucking does,
right?
They fucking debt.
Literally watching them lose,
gives other people hope,
you know,
gives you hope that you can call up your cable company,
dispute the bill and get some money off of it.
Right.
Gives you a hope that she can fuck in a,
you know,
an elected politician and they,
they,
they're going to fucking not sell out to the corporations.
You know what I mean?
That that's what the Patriots have become,
that that's their level of fucking success.
There's going to be a lot of slumped shoulders go to work tomorrow or maybe
right now.
Maybe you're one of those people,
maybe you're driving in your car right now and you showed us as so slumped.
You're not even using your hands to fucking steer.
He gets got your shoulders fucking wrapped around it.
Just all fucking
caved in is the thrill ride says right.
Okay.
Maybe one of those people.
Well,
you know what I say fucking grow up,
right?
It's just a God damn game.
I would've taken the loss.
I was already ready already.
I was sitting there writing my fucking concession speech.
You know
unfucking believable.
All right,
let's get out of this fucking four techs here.
I only know if I got the advertising yet for this week.
Oh yeah.
So the game plans,
I'm going to buy that fucking kit and then I'm going to find some rehearsal
space somewhere nearby.
Some fucking place for a couple of hundred bucks a month.
And I'm going to fucking put it in there.
All right?
And whenever I can't,
that's going to be my fucking man cave.
All right?
Cause you know what the fuck happens.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You have a kid,
you're married,
you know,
gradually all the shit just starts fucking disappeared.
Okay.
My wife can't fucking wait.
She can't,
she couldn't fucking,
you know.
Okay,
she's happy.
I like the drums,
but no fucking woman wants a fucking
okay.
26 inch bass drum in a fucking travel case,
like I'm on the fucking road with the rolling stones in another fucking four
drum stacked up on top of that,
you know,
in front of the bed,
in the guest room.
Nobody fucking wants it.
Well,
they don't want that.
So,
um,
I don't know,
but you know what?
I got to give this to her.
She never told me to sell the fucking thing.
All I know is when I told her that I was selling it,
I saw the excitement in a right.
And then I tested her and I was saying,
yeah,
but then I'm going to go buy another one and it's going to live right there.
And then she just stared at me and I just started laughing.
Um,
okay.
I'm trying not to be a dick though.
Now that I,
you know,
our dynamic has changed.
You know,
like I'm going to put my truck in fucking storage and I'll,
ah,
drive it on the weekends.
I know there's a lot of married guys.
Why not going out?
You're never going to drive it and then you're going to fucking sell it.
Um,
I actually thought about selling it to,
you know,
just this whole fucking streamline and mine in my life,
getting my fucking shit down.
But um,
okay.
I can't fucking do it.
I just,
when I drive that truck,
this stupid smile on my fucking face.
It's just I can't do it.
Yeah.
Can't fucking do it.
So I'm just going to put it in storage and I'll eat that fucking money.
I hate being the storage guy.
I get stuff in storage.
Yeah.
If people have stuff in storage are just too lazy to have a fucking yard sale,
you know what I mean?
Just fucking salad.
Sell it.
How long has it been there?
What is,
you know,
it's funny just hanging onto those fucking memories.
It's,
I'm telling you,
dude,
it's a fucking disease.
And I got it.
I got it bad.
I'm a sentimental fool.
I gotta I gotta get rid of all of that shit.
I never look at it.
It just becomes another box in the fucking attic,
you know,
and you fucking die some day.
And then somebody looking through it and there's all this weird shit in there
that you kept some menu from fucking Tulsa,
Oklahoma for whatever.
Well,
what the fuck is it then?
You know,
he just given these people this big job that they got to go and throw their shit
up.
Yeah.
How is this sona fucking,
is this a website?
Oh,
that's seminar.
The Nam show or all the shredders.
Go
see here.
You know,
it was in a Sam ash the other day,
right.
And uh,
I wanted to see if they had it.
What the fuck do I know?
I went there.
I actually can't say why I went there.
I won't get caught.
I just had all these extra drum sticks and I had all this shit that I was
getting rid of that I just don't fucking use.
And I'm like,
what am I gonna do with this stuff?
I can't sell old drum sticks on a fucking on Ebay or some shit.
So what I did was I just bundled them all together and just left them in their
parking lot.
You know,
some kids get to walk in there and be like,
Holy Shit,
I had like 40 pairs of fucking all these different drum sticks over the years.
I just bundle them all.
Just stuck in there like a fucking cow bell.
A couple of the things.
So at that point I'm like,
all right.
I guess kind of was feeling guilty.
So I went into Sam ash.
It was like,
I don't buy a fucking pair of drumsticks.
And there was some kid in there just doing that fucking drum and where he's
amazing,
but all the whole fucking thing.
It's just one fill after another,
those fucking
linear 32nd note.
Fucking Phil's played 9 million miles an hour every fucking after.
It just all sounds the same.
But don't,
we don't get Dr [inaudible] for fucking like,
I almost started laughing because the kid was amazing,
but after awhile it's just like,
dude,
you sound like you're fucking,
you sound like a fucking snorted a couple of eight balls.
Jesus Christ.
Maybe I'm just getting old.
I was,
well,
I put a little air in there.
You know,
the old guy who can't play as good as a young kid and he's jealous of his chops,
but Jesus Christ.
All right,
what am I doing here?
I'm trying to find the fucking,
um,
here we go.
The live reads.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Sherry Barry.
There's no one like your Valentine this year.
Treat them to an unforgettable gift.
This is a unique as they are to chocolate covered strawberries is pretty
pedestrian,
isn't it?
Yeah,
you're really fucking unique.
Kiss,
uh,
is,
um,
is a fucking,
is a matzah cracker with a little butter on it.
Well,
fuck you.
Oh,
it's delicious.
It's a timeless classic.
What you're saying is there a timeless classic when I think in a way,
or maybe you're saying they're old,
is an old people gift.
All right.
I give from Sherry's berries.
Shows,
shows her,
you put thought into finding the perfect gift.
Why can't,
why can't the women by guys chocolate covered strawberries?
Is this,
does this read sexist?
All right,
here we go.
Freshly dipped strawberries from Sherry's berries starting at just 1999 plus
shipping or double the berries for just $10 more.
Just go to Barry's dot Com B e r r I e s.com and use my code burr helps support
our show by supporting our sponsors.
Use My code bar surprise or at the office slash works workplace.
What are you going to throw a matter?
Her coworkers are sure to be.
Just a little jealous.
Yeah,
just a little oh,
chocolate strawberries.
Oh Jesus.
Somebody got a hand job last night and she'll be overjoyed.
I'm joking.
These things are fucking delicious.
Sorry.
Choose a gift from Sherry's berries.
Incredible collection of gifts.
Your gifts will be perfectly packaged in a gift box with all the details taken
care of.
Sherry's berries will deliver your gift fresh and on time guaranteed or your
money back with Valentine's Day right around the corner.
There's only one way to get Sherry's berries starting at 1999 why don't they,
why did they write all that bullshit?
Who's fucking kid and hope your red guy got to get her something.
You don't want to fucking do it.
Just get just,
just get her this or get or something else and get her this pad.
The fucking thing,
like the Lakers with their championships at this one.
This is your NBL fucking title.
You'd thrown 20 bucks.
Chocolate covered strawberries.
You know what I mean?
So you got the gift and then he gave her some shit.
You know it's got sugar in it.
It will make her fucking give her a little rush,
right?
It's a joke.
Just visit [inaudible] Dot Com B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone in the top right hand corner and type in Burr.
That's berries.com and use my code burr helps support our show by supporting our
sponsors.
Used my code.
Ah,
the classics,
Bobo,
Mandy's beyond ease.
Degrade is of all fucking time.
But due to be Andy's beyond these,
all your counts have to whine.
When you say Brady's the best,
he probably got velvet balls too,
so he doesn't need me undies.
Who gives a fuck?
He's got a ring for every finger on his right hand.
All right,
this Valentine's Day give a gift that they can unwrap again and again.
Matching underwear from me undies.
Valentine's Day is near and it's got and it's go time for thoughtful gift
hunting me undies has you covered with limited edition matching pairs of undies
for you and yours.
This is such an odd gift.
This,
she was like,
come with like a sex swing or something.
Um,
has Valentine's Day got you stumped.
Forget the cliches and give the gift.
That looks great.
It feels great and will make everyone happy.
Me undies.
Fancy dinners and chocolate last night.
Shots fired flowers last a week,
eh,
comment this year.
Give the gift of looking great and feeling great every day with the world's most
comfortable underwear.
Heads up.
Valentine's Day is February 14th,
February six.
Guys,
you got fucking,
I always got to say guys,
right?
Because women,
you don't have to fucking do anything.
What are you gonna do?
Huh?
Fucking push your tits together and throw a little perfume down in the middle.
What else do you got to do?
Put on a thong.
Alright,
Valentine's days when it's fortunate.
I don't panic.
Get your heart,
get your heart on and show some love with me undies.
Matching undies.
Please include all of the following points during your read.
Oh yeah,
of course I will.
Me undies or the perfect gift for you and your Valentine this holiday.
They're unbelievably soft and coming.
Limited edition prints.
We've,
we've got all this,
I'm not reading all this shit.
Okay.
This is the,
okay,
they got fucking underwear.
It matches.
It's,
it's cute.
You know,
remember back in the day when people had like a fucking answer machine and they
would do it together.
Like hello,
this is the Johnsons and together we're happy.
You know they do I fucking horse shit.
This is the underwear version of that.
All right.
Mandy says special limited edition Valentines undies,
which means you and your Valentine's can match and yeah,
it's just cute as it sounds slash creepy.
And if for some reason you and me on these aren't a perfect match,
they'll give you your money back and let you keep the first parent.
There's no refund on a bad,
fancy dinner.
All right?
They offer free shipping and for a limited time listeners to this stage,
you get 20% off their first order,
but you have to go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] with [inaudible] m e
u n D,
I,
e.
S.
Better day guarantee you have nothing to lose,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash burr all right,
what do we got left?
Two more.
Hang in there.
Pro Flow.
Are you tired of guessing what she wants for Valentine's Day?
Maybe you're a little sick of her.
What are you doing in that relationship?
Huh?
Why the fuck would you waste your time getting flowers,
but maybe it's still lover when you love an easy failproof way to look like a
pro this year,
pro flowers is making it easier than ever by taking all the guesswork out on top
of their already low prices.
Right now.
You can get two dozen assorted roses with a free glass case for 2,999 plus
shipping and handling or upgrade in for nine 99 more.
You can get two dozen long stem assorted roses with premium vase and chocolate.
Just go to proflowers.com use my our upgrade even more
and have a Gigolo delivered that.
Just fuck your wife while you watch the replay.
The Patriots can't come on man.
Okay,
you can bang your wife whenever you want to.
When are you going to watch a man?
When his fifth fucking Superbowl ring as a quarterback,
I'm sorry,
shouldn't have said that.
Just go to proflowers.com and use my code burr.
Help support the show by supporting our sponsors.
Use My code burb Borr pick your flowers and then check out in two minutes.
I've done this before.
I did it for my mother.
I did it on mother's Day.
It was easy as hell.
You just go there,
big bank bulb,
Zippity Doo Dah,
and then they go,
oh,
and you never left your desk.
You could literally put down your game.
Boy,
knock this out and fucking two minutes and go right back to talking shit online.
All right.
You can't beat the price and convenience.
Proflowers takes care of the details.
You can just sit back and look.
Awesome.
When I send flowers,
I trust Plouffe pro flowers to get it right.
The only,
yeah,
that's my quarterback,
my quarterback pro flowers.
Here's the only way to get two dozen assorted roses with a free glass vase
starting@twentynineninetyninejustgotoproflowers.com use my code burr helps
support support our show by supporting our sponsors.
Use My code Burr,
that's proflowers.com click on the microphone and type in my code burr.
Don't wait.
Order today.
This deal expires soon.
And finally,
lastly,
but not leastly dollar shave club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club always gives you a close,
smooth shave and you can't beat the convenience or the price.
You don't have to choose between settling for a cheap bag of disposables or
paying out the nose for a razor with a laser pointer and 17 blades.
It's awful.
Then dollar shave club broke onto the scene with the smarter choice.
Before Dollar Shave Club,
there was no middle ground.
There was the haves and the have nots.
It was easy.
It was either saved money and get a painful shave from a disposable,
like the ones that you get for free to a gym,
which felt like shaving with a piece of glass or pay a fortune for the latest
shaved breakthrough in quotes,
you didn't need like a laser chin detector are 17 more blades.
It was fucking stupid.
Dollar Shave Club is the best of both worlds.
You get a premium shape quality at,
uh,
at disposable shape prices.
If you haven't tried dollar shave club yet,
you're missing out.
I don't know what the fuck you waiting for.
It's an amazing shave at an affordable price.
Don't just sit there with a dumb look on your face.
Go to dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] there's no smarter choice on the market
and right now they're giving away a one month trial of any of their razors for
only a dollar with free shipping.
And after that,
it's just a few bucks a month.
There's no long term commitments,
no hidden fees.
And you can cancel whenever you want.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right.
There you go.
Okay,
that's done.
Let's,
uh,
let's all go to the lobby.
Bup,
bup up,
boo boo.
All right,
let's,
um,
let's read some of these fucking things.
Uh,
eight.
Did I call it a what?
I said it was going to be a classic,
although I don't know if I can,
it's a classic for one side.
I thought it was gonna be a classic for both,
for both sides,
but I'm all right enough,
Bill.
Okay.
The fucking Atlanta fans have suffered enough.
Let's just fucking get through this.
Okay.
Alright.
First football game,
watched from sweet,
uh,
Bill Birdie,
being from speed,
saying that football is big here as an understatement.
I don't know how they talk over there,
but I,
that's actually a Swedish accent,
isn't it?
I have no idea.
Uh,
but I've been listening to your podcast for a couple of years now and you're
rambling over.
Nfl have made me interested.
I'll look at them.
Maybe you just got me a job at the NFL,
you know,
maybe I could be on when you're a little Google things in your rump
as you fucking talk and whenever the hell you guys speak over there.
Right.
Each magic version.
That's what it sounds like to me.
I can't imagine what I sound like to you.
Probably a fucking asshole.
All right.
I finally sat down and watched a game and it was the Superbowl that just ended
and what a game.
I'm sold Jesus Christ.
When the fuck did this guy send this in?
I love hockey mostly,
but I found a new game to love.
Tom Brady.
Best Qb ever says the Swedish commentators.
I have no clue,
but I believed them,
I guess.
Uh,
thanks for getting me into the game.
Better late than never.
I love people who've could speak a second language that's fucking amazing.
Sorry for the bad English grammar dude.
He did the fucking Boston accent perfectly in a second language.
He says it's early and I'm tired.
All the best to you.
Nia and the newborn baby girl loved the special.
Looking forward to season two was,
uh,F is for family.
You know,
it's funny,
I was just thinking I got to get over there.
I missed you guys in the last tour.
I didn't do the Norway,
the Oslo,
Stockholm,
Helsinki run.
I got to make sure I do that at some point.
Um,
okay.
But,
uh,
any one,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
um,
I don't want to rain on your parade,
but you just w you know,
most football games are not that exciting.
Do you know how boring the first half was?
Well,
I guess for me it was depressing.
I guess it was exciting for Atlanta fans.
Okay.
Oh God,
I can't,
you know,
I had a buddy of mine,
mmm.
Actually he recently passed away,
which sucks,
but he told me this fucking story.
Okay.
When the red sox had like two outs in 1986 against the mets,
he had the wire office,
champagne bottle,
and he had to put it back on after they lost.
Hey baby,
this'll be
for Atlanta fence.
This'll be cathartic for you.
If you want to share your,
uh,
I thought we were going to win stories and then I had to put the fucking wire
back on the champagne bottle.
I'll read them next week.
Um,
or anybody out there,
if you have those,
we're going to fucking win and then you lose the fucking game.
Um,
I got a bunch of them I can share with you.
Uh,
I got a bunch of those.
Um,
those could be fucking really,
fas are fucking always hilarious.
It's so,
that's comedy man itself.
When if it works out,
there's no comedy.
It's white.
When
what'd you find?
Like if the Patriots fucking got their asses kicked out of it,
that would have,
I already knew I was going.
We just got our asses wept.
I had the whole fucking thing worked out steady.
Came on gushing here.
Like I just won the fucking publisher's clearinghouse.
I cannot fucking believe they came back and won that game.
That is,
I fucking stunned.
CanNot fucking believe that.
All right.
British dentistry.
Hey Bill.
I remember hearing that you used to be a dentist before your standup career took
off.
So I have a dental quest for you.
I was not a dentist,
but I love that you put that out there.
And then I'll probably end up on my a Wikipedia page.
Um,
I don't know why we British don't take dental care seriously.
I have pretty decent teeth for British person,
probably in the top 15% of people,
British people.
That is,
I always brushed twice a day unless they get drunk and forget sometimes after
going out drinking.
But I noticed that when I was in America,
my teeth were shit,
what the fuck are you lot over there in the land of Mcdonald's and Coca Cola
doing to keep your teeth so clean?
Is their toothpaste in the water supply or there was fluoride?
Sometimes they put in too much and people got those white spots in their teeth a
seriously.
Uh,
do you do,
do you lot live at the dentist a lot?
Meaning all you guys,
even the working class over in America seem to have good teeth?
Uh,
yeah,
we do.
Well,
I mean,
uh,
braces are a big thing over here.
I don't know if you guys have those over there yet.
Uh,
those are a big thing.
People also can get like their teeth bleached caps are a lot better than they
used to be.
Um,
yeah.
But at the end of the day,
dude,
you gotta brush your teeth FTE and there's certain things like drinking coffee.
I guess your tea over there would probably stay in the shit out of him.
I'll tell you one that's fucking brutal.
Red Wine,
red,
red.
Wow.
Makes your teeth gray.
Um,
yeah,
just brush and floss.
You know,
I got this life insurance test coming up cause I'm getting my affairs in order
now that I've got a kid.
Um,
they told me,
they said,
have you been to the dentist?
And I said,
yes.
I said,
well,
is any gum disease?
And I said No.
And they said,
that's good.
I said,
oh,
I go,
they're worried about my teeth falling out.
And they said,
no gum disease can be a sign of something wrong with your heart.
I was like,
what?
I never heard.
I never heard that.
Never heard that.
I know if he had fucked up teeth that usually,
and led to you not a chewing your food as well,
which lead to stomach problems and then problems with your intestine and then
down to your ash.
It's all fucking connected.
Um,
but I had never heard of that.
So anyways,
he said to put in perspective how bad some British people are with dental
hygiene.
I know someone who would only brush their teeth once or twice a week.
I had to buy them an electric toothbrush as a not so subtle hint that not
brushing your teeth is fucking disgusting.
I guess there's a lot of truth to stereotypes.
PSL.
Be Amazed if you actually managed to read this without stuttering,
you illiterate.
Fuck,
uh,
you know something.
If that whole fucking thing was just to get that joke and that was an absolute
masterpiece,
you know,
if you actually just pick that subject,
British stenner street,
just to fool us.
So we would actually read it and was all self deprecating,
just the end,
just to call me a fucking illiterate.
Fuck.
The stuttering illiterate fuck is great.
I have a tremendous,
um,
I don't even know if you're serious anymore,
but yeah,
that's,
listen,
I,
when I worked in a dental office,
all I did was just hand the shit.
I was an assistant.
I was certified to take x rays.
I wasn't a hygienist.
I wasn't any of that other shit.
MMM.
So anyways,
um,
yeah,
that was one of my first jokes.
This guy came in and guy was like,
you know,
I don't stand in front of my teeth.
And I brushed my teeth almost every day at,
my joke was,
oh really?
Dee Dee a wipe your ass.
Almost every time you take a shit that may come on people is this thing on.
It's one of my first jokes.
Everybody there was a,
what do they call it?
Throwback Thursday.
Now I'm actress paying alimony.
If you just brush your fucking teeth,
I think you'll be fine.
MMM.
You know?
And especially before you go to bed to just like go out drinking and doing all
that shit and then just go to bed and just let that shit just get it.
It's gross.
It's fucking gross.
She brush floss.
And you should use mouthwash,
you know,
and then you should find a fucking woman that does the same thing.
And that's the person you should be kissing over there.
Everybody else,
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
That's fucking gross.
Anyways,
actress paying alimony.
Bill wondering if you saw this,
a fairly famous actress has been paying or unemployed husband alimony,
and she's complaining that he hasn't tried to get a job.
She's paying him 20 grand a month.
Does that make him a bum?
Okay.
Is this like a trick question?
If I had a son that ever fucking did that,
I would disown him.
That's fucking unbelievable.
I've seen that.
You know that that does happen when one of the,
uh,
alright,
here we go.
Let's let me read this thing here.
Uh,
according to a court document,
okay,
So-and-so is paid over a half a million dollars to her former spouse since 2015.
Yeah.
These funds include around 150,000.
Okay.
And such,
it's such residuals.
I'm not going to say who the fuck this is.
I put people's dirty laundry out there even though it's already out here.
MMM.
She gave birth to that daughter in March of last year.
It's person alleges that the other guy cheated on him
with the,
Oh,
he's saying that she cheated on him with her costar.
A point of contention in the divorce.
The divorce has since been finalized.
The terms of support have not,
hence a temporary agreement where she has to pay this dude over 20 grand
monthly.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
if they do get divorced shift,
she's out here in California,
she's going to get fucked according to documents.
So-And-So is requested to be able to stop sending the guy those payments saying
that the guy has made no effort to get a job of his own and his living off of
her.
Uh,
yeah,
man.
I mean,
that's when you just start thinking murderous thoughts,
you know,
I
think that's a,
yeah.
You know,
it's bad enough when a fucking woman does it.
I mean,
I'm really doing like a double standard here.
Okay.
But,
uh,
yeah,
dude.
I mean,
you're not a fucking man if you do something like that.
And if you're a woman and you don't try to get a job,
you're a piece of shit.
But you know what?
I know that you don't give a fuck.
So you know,
women don't give a shit.
They actually get off of the fact that you fucking,
you know,
am I really going to turn this around?
Just slamming women?
I mean,
really gonna figure out how to do that.
When does a woman,
the woman's a victim in this Belfer.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
that's complete bullshit.
It's complete bullshit.
I straight across the board think that's fucked up.
All right.
Now.
Okay,
she's a fucking drug addict and he has to stay at home the entire time to watch
their kid.
I mean,
they just had their kid that is actually his job.
They understand.
You know what I mean?
MMM.
Oh God.
Then for the grace of God go,
I,
Holy Shit.
I just don't understand how it gets to that.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
How'd he get to that point where you're with somebody,
you have a fucking kid.
I'm probably jinxing myself.
You have a kid together
and then eight,
like he decided to make another person together and within a fucking
two years of that,
okay,
you're getting the of Jesus Christ be one thing.
If they had a one night stand but they were already married,
that's,
that's fucking nuts.
All right.
Who knows?
Maybe the guy just went nuts.
Maybe she did fuck around them.
I don't know.
All right.
Coaching daughters,
uh,
sports teams,
coaching.
Dot.
Well,
it's supposed to be,
uh,
an apostrophe there.
Coaching Daughter's sports team.
All right.
Congrats.
Yeah.
On not pulling out.
Ha Ha.
No,
thank you.
I was wondering if you will coach any of your daughter's sports teams when she
gets older.
What sports would you like to see her grow up to play?
Congratulations to you and Nia and thank you for another grade special.
Um,
oh,
you're welcome.
I'm glad you enjoyed it.
Um,
would I do that?
Uh,
okay.
I don't know.
I don't want to insert myself into my daughter's life like that.
I'd like her to have to learn how to deal with another adult and especially if
she doesn't like him and learn how to fucking,
you know,
deal with a coach sets a little hard nose.
So whatever,
you know,
I mean,
I'm not going to be one of those people that,
you know,
blew my fucking kid.
If my kid stinks,
I'm not going to
can make them play my kid.
Right?
I'm not going to be the,
I've just all of that shit.
I don't understand any of that.
And if your coach is fucking hard nose and your kid comes home crying about it,
it's literally told toughen the fuck up.
Yeah.
Learn on a deal what you think.
This is the first asshole you ever going to fucking run into in life.
It's,
it's not.
You know,
you know what worked twice as hard.
Okay.
Make that fucking guy regret that he ever yelled at you.
Oh,
that woman,
that's what you do.
You just,
you just go fucking harder.
That's what you do.
What you don't do is fucking mope around about it and,
and try less.
All right?
If your motivation,
even if your motivation is fuck this guy,
you know you're going to play better,
but you got to use that negative shit and turn it into a positive.
And um,
I'm a big believer in uh,
playing organized sports in organized sports has gotten a brutal reputation over
the years.
Some of it is justified,
a lot of it wasn't,
a lot of,
it was a bunch of uncoordinated people who did not have a good fucking
experience and then married someone else who was also on coordinated and then
watch their toddler growing up,
bumping into shit and was like,
oh my God,
they're going to suck at sports too and they're going to have the same pain that
I did or I had.
Right.
And then rather than steering them away from sports and going,
well,
hey,
maybe you are a writer or maybe you're into science.
These fucking uncoordinated cons had to stick them in sports.
And then they had the dumb,
the whole thing down where everybody gets a ribbon.
I had a buddy of mine recently said,
what was it?
Somebody doing a joke,
I can't say it.
If it was a joke,
who the fuck told me this story?
It was was,
no,
it was somebody bit,
I can't do it.
Uh,
fuck it had to do basically with playing,
uh,
little kids playing softball and when they first played they played without the
ball and they pretended that they hit the fucking thing so nobody would have the
pressure of making an error and they could be like nice catch way to go and all
of that shit.
It's fucking insane.
Um,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
And unfortunately my wife is on the same page and uh,
I told you that shit.
Somebody sent us some,
uh,
Boston,
you know,
sports shirts and they were,
they would,
you know,
with the logos of the teams and they were in pink and my wife was just going
like,
yeah,
she's not wearing those.
And I'm like,
why?
Cause you hate sports.
And she goes,
no,
because they're pink.
She goes,
if she's going to wear the team stuff,
she's,
she's wearing the team colors.
I think I already told you this guys.
I was like,
do you have any fucking idea how much real sports fans would appreciate what you
just said?
You don't even like sports.
You have no fucking idea.
You just,
you just like,
you stepped in shit there.
That's like the,
that's exactly it.
Um,
anyway,
I don't have no fucking idea.
So we'll,
I coach.
Um,
no,
I wouldn't do that.
You know what,
if I was ever to coach,
I would be a,
I think I would be an assistant coach.
I'd be the Rah Rah guy if they were little and shit deck.
I couldn't fucking
sit there yelling at kids.
Um,
and also I don't think I know enough about the fucking game.
I've watched a bunch of sports,
but to actually coach a team and teach somebody how to get better,
I mean,
I think I'd be,
I'm,
I'll be a good dad if she wants to be a go in the backyard,
learn how to hit a ball or shoot some baskets.
I think I'm good at that.
But like,
you know,
that's a hell of a responsibility.
And I have a very volatile personality and I just,
I don't want to be the Earl weaver of fucking eight year olds out there
screaming and yell at Bull.
We'll see.
We'll see other meditating and possibly going to therapy works out.
But
MMM.
I'm more excited just to see what she gravitates to.
I'm going to expose her to as much music and different shit as I possibly can
and then just sort of stand back,
see what she goes after and then just encourage her and if it's like a fee,
if it's a phase,
it's a phase and then she moves onto something else.
But my parents were really cool about kind of letting us do
mmm.
You know,
whatever the fuck we wanted to do.
Uh,
as far as trying shit in life.
Like my parents never gave me shit about being a standup comedian.
And,
um,
okay.
That's pretty,
uh,
when I,
you know,
the amount of comics that I've run into where to this day,
like they're super successful and their parents still don't even respect what
they do,
thinking that they're just up there fucking around.
Um,
it's pretty amazing.
So I got really lucky in that department.
So that's one of the good things that I'm keeping from my,
uh,
my upbringing.
So long story short,
uh,
no,
but I will go to every fucker game.
I'll go to every game and I'm not going to argue with other parents and die if
the,
if the fucking referee stinks and is screwing my team,
I'm just going to sit there and just,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just not going to be that fucking guy.
I'm going to make jokes and I'm move.
I'll be laughing.
But uh,
you know what the big thing is,
is when I go to her games,
I'm going to be sober.
So
that's gonna really toned down.
It's when I go to games that I've had a few,
I can't resist as a crowd.
There's jokes to be made.
Even way back in the day when I was fucking,
you know,
way more introverted.
I had a couple of beers and I would be Sullivan Stadium and I would yell out
shit.
And people in my section would laugh and I would just build my confidence and
suck some game teams.
I would yell out the first thing it would bomb and then I would say anything
again until the third quarter and then I'd throw it out,
but only have like,
you know,
50% confidence.
So it only did okay.
And it'd be like my,
literally my bad setback then like bombing was,
I went to a game and I yelled out some shit and nobody laughed.
But I dunno,
it's not the way it used to be because everybody's so concerned about kids and
political correctness and fucking public drunkenness and shit.
But back in the day,
like
what was going on in the field was,
was about half as entertaining is what was going on in the stance.
It was just,
and it was all just sophomore acts stupid.
Okay.
I remember sitting,
we had like N.
Dot.
N zones,
seats.
We were sitting right at the corner.
MMM.
You know,
like past the goal line.
We basically sitting like facing the end zone and then there was the end zone
seats and they used to have this beer commercial,
a light beer from Miller.
And they used to have the big fights,
less filling tastes great,
less filling tastes like they were having a fight,
you know,
over over if it didn't fill you up as much or if it tasted better.
So that became like this stupid thing that people did.
You'd be at,
at,
at uh,
someone figured out one time,
stood up and yelled at the other section,
said less filling at someone else,
stood up and screamed,
taste great.
And then we'd all be yelling like,
hey,
we're doing the commercial,
this is before youtube.
So this was actually fun.
So it'd be one session
less.
Ellie thanks.
Glad last time.
Great.
In a course because it was a bunch of drunks,
drunk males.
It immediately went sophomores and it eventually became Yep,
fuck you a chat.
Fuck you ain't shit.
And we would do that 20 times a game and it would be just as funny the 20th time
as it was the first time cause we were all a bunch of immature fucking idiots.
I miss those days,
you know,
I really fucking Miss Duck.
That was lot of fun back then.
Now it's just so you know the balls in play.
Don't go to your seed this from fucking old lady with a construction hat on
telling you to stop.
I don't know.
Ah,
I'm just a fucking curmudgeon.
What are you going to do?
But anyways,
uh,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you guys so much for listening and thank you everybody who's been watching
my special and giving me the great reviews,
um,
uh,
really proud of this special.
And if you haven't had a chance to watch it,
please check it out.
Obviously that helps me out with my relationship with Netflix and my ability to
do eventually do another one.
And um,
if you've already seen it and you enjoyed it,
uh,
please tell somebody else to check it out and that's it.
And congratulations to the New England patriots.
Holy Shit.
Championship number five.
Unbelievable.
And once again,
I'm not fucking around here.
My condolences to Atlanta fans.
I,
uh,
I have been there.
It fucking sucks.
But you guys got a hell of a team and I hope your back.
Then next year when you get you get your fucking window,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves or check in on you.
Check in on you on Thursday and all you concent,
Charlotte.
I'll see ya on a Wednesday.
All right.